As you know, the
appointment to Matignon
of the young burgeoning Gabriel Attal,
34 years old,
is 1
missile to stop the rise of Jordan Bardella
to the elections
European elections of 09/06,
but not only.
It is not forbidden to think that Emmanuel Macron
had another idea in mind,
brake on his left 1 other opponent,
the MEP Raphaël gluxman.
Because the future champion of the PS list more public
could well
suck the disappointed defenders of Macronism
who plug their noses at the right-hand corner of the
government and who,
no doubt not,
was very reassured by the great
President's press conference
with extreme center populist accents.
They go up,
they go up in the polls,
Raphaël gluxman,
credited with 10 to 11% of voting intentions,
almost double its score of two thousand nineteen,
6,2%.
And the danger is all the greater
for the Macronie that this UFO half-activist,
half-essayist who refreshes 1 political landscape,
sclerosis,
received the support of someone very close to the president,
the pope of the green Daniel conbendit,
the one who had brought the glasses to the score
16.3% fee
in the European elections 15 years ago.
Raphael Gluxman understood this well,
he must do everything possible to prevent the debate of the
European elections can be summed up in,
which will be
the best bulwark against the National Rally?
We will not let the game Atal Bardella
his elections,
they warn.
That's why we see it a little
everywhere these days in the media.
He has already started his campaign,
because to leave.
From May 27?
Well,
he will suffer the terrible blow
near the fairness of the speaking time,
in two thousand nineteen,
to give you an idea,
in the last 15 days of the European campaign,
while the Macronist list
had 55 minutes of speaking time,
The National Rally of 48 had only 20.
With his eight hundred thousand followers on Instagram
and three hundred thousand on X,
the one who became known
by its
fight against wig by China
or against fast fashion
therefore multiplies the positions taken.
For example for 1 European tax on the super rich
to massively finance the ecological transition.
Or for 1 European defense.
Because,
he warns,
his elections,
the first since the war is
back on the ground
European Union in Ukraine,
may be more important than the
Welcome to France.
Yes Donald
Trump was re-elected in the United States in November.
As he says,
have we ever thought about what would happen if
dad was leaving the house
and left us all alone facing Vladimir ?
Nine/06,
it is perhaps also 1 little of the future of the left
French that is played out.
Raphael Gluxman's supporters
hope to see it weigh in the future
on the recomposition of a realistic left,
reformist,
liberated
finally from the grip of Jean-Luc Mélenchon's insoumis.
As he says funny,
they take us for Care Bears,
but we are pirates